after Terminator 3 let you down
salvation left you bored and Genesis had
you wondering what you've done to
deserve this they finally made a decent
Terminator movie only now no one gives
us you know you think out of all the
franchises this one would have a better
sense of timing terminator dark fate
do you like the first two terminators
well what if they did that again but
this time Kyle Reese was a girl John
Connor was a girl and everything else
was the same from the characters to the
action
to the dialog I'll be back I'll be back
I'll be back
sorta come with me if you want to live
come with me if you want to live 30
seconds and in a brand-new twist half of
it is in Mexico how do you not work
hasta LaVista in of this one it was
right there
forget everything that happened in the
last three films and done and scrapped
it in for a story that picks up a few
years after t2 then instantly makes that
whole movie pointless but if you can
shake that off
you're in for a back-to-basics
Terminator picture where law enforcement
does the die
the time travelers do the futures
detailing future and the guns don't do
much of anything
the old step and shoot and step and
shoot a terminator tradition Linda
Hamilton returns as Sarah Connor a
survivor trapped in an endless cycle of
reboots a terminator drops out
so I destroy it and then two years later
same thing but she's not the only badass
with let me speak to your manager hair
there's grace and enhanced human with a
couple of minutes of super strength in
her before she gets white-girl wasted
they'll form an unlikely alliance with
the t800 model who killed John Connor
then used his newfound free will to
become a celibate Texan drape salesman
our relationship is not physical
I had the drapes weird flex but all
right all to protect Danny the Future
leader of humanity's resistance
thanks to her powerful message robots
bad you should be fighting the machines
Oh for real Wow never thought of that -
you brought it up guess you're in charge
then get ready to run from the all-new t
rev1980 model with the power to split
itself in twos and make itself a goo but
like all good terminators this
unthinking killing machine won't
hesitate to dramatically hesitate and
when this monster made of living knives
gets too close to a main character you
can bet he'll shove up real hard
and before he kills you
you can bet he'll disarm you with cold
calculating manners on us - the sorry
evening sorry about your [ __ ] he's not
so bad I forgot robot
bad so as all of our faves get old enjoy
another installment in the localization
of pop culture where a franchise film
comes out that doesn't dwell on the
terrible sequels brings back a grizzled
ass-kicker gives them a mean case of
PTSD pairs that with a young girl to
hopefully take over from here and has
them do all the stuff you like but just
differently enough to eke another 10 to
20 bucks out of you before dementia sets
in and every movie feels new again I'll
be back we know story Joan Connor she
protect but she also attacked Cooper
trooper Kaena
bawd Carl gone in 60 seconds and the
American healthcare system we have a
doctor's prescription terminator dose
[Music]
they took our jobs
hey screen junkies what if the Joker did
all that Joker stuff in real life what
would he be charged with could his
lawyer use the insanity defense we
wasted a real attorneys time to find out
in this all new video Jessica only child
illinois-chicago
you're fond of me lobster ain't you uh